this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app it's the
number one finance app on the app store
well you might not know is that you can
put cash app in your wallet with the
cash card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one we're gonna talk about this cash app
and why it's the number one finance app
in the App Store a little bit later on
in the show but you can download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market now we got it forgot
to do the Tings
so that's what we're doing here we're
backing up the [ __ ] Brinks try
it you know how it goes and a lot of
people are taking that Brinks truck the
[ __ ] metaphor and running with it so
they might switch on over to Dunbar
that's all I'm saying
you see those red and black they're not
vans trucks
you see those money trucks well we're in
a new deal you know that [ __ ] we
don't like to do without the people do
so we're trying to get done but it
doesn't really have a ring to it does it
but it doesn't matter who gives a [ __ ]
about rings we're live on my app right
now which means if you're hearing this
and you're not on my app you've heard it
after the people who have my app so you
can go download my app right now so next
time you can hear and see this podcast
before anyone else it's a day before on
the visual and it's like hours before on
the audio so anyway that's it and it is
it is October man it's gonna be November
already and you know people always say
that [ __ ] they're always just like wow
man it's November it's gonna be November
already I can't believe it's May oh my
god is already March well what the [ __ ]
yeah months just happened as quick as
they happen and that's it and maybe
you're just not paying attention that's
all and that's fine but you don't have
to be like wow can't believe it's
[ __ ] December already because the
year is always as long as the year
okay now there's also Loomis armored
trucks did you know that so maybe we're
backing up Blume is it maybe we're
backing up Loomis trucks maybe that's
what we're doing we don't know we don't
really subscribe to one company when
they have to [ __ ] dump out money on
mmm driveway do you know what I mean but
you know whoever's gonna come in an
armored truck Rovers gonna come in an
armored truck and I'm like that [ __ ]
scrooge mcduck guy just diving in a
[ __ ] big pile of coins by the way
would hurt himself so much if he did
that remember that duck tail [ __ ] he
would just dive in he would die he had a
diving board and he would dive into a
bunch of gold coins and and then like
come up and just spit nicked it like
nickels out and coins out he would be
dead also he was [ __ ] eighty you know
if an 80 year old really duck dove into
a bunch of coins in a vault like that he
would [ __ ] first of all he wouldn't
be able to do the backstroke like how
Scrooge McDuck can do it but he would
die immediately so that's just a little
bit of your realness of your oh they did
it in Family Guy
that's funny where he dives in the thing
and he breaks his dude every time I
[ __ ] say something Family Guy already
did this [ __ ] it's cuz been on for 11
years it sucks so anyway so anyway so
why even try comedy wise you know what
[ __ ] it I quit I quit I quit uh you
remember that [ __ ] part in that thing
we do that doing that thing you do wow
that was so funny I want to quit like
that guy quits in that thing you do no
matter what I'm doing I want to quit
like that no matter what it is in my
life
I wish I had a [ __ ] regular job
sometimes just so I can go in and be
like I quit imagine if you walked into
your job or you were like working at the
bank and you're just and you're just
like you know what and your boss was
like we really need this to happen
you're just like I quit
quit oh man that guy will be my hero I
would follow that guy to the ends of the
earth
do you understand and that's what I want
to do follow me to the end of the earth
well I'm seven uh anyway uh I got a
question for you guys right now
are you guys feeling spooky cuz you know
what's coming up Halloween you know what
the most annoying is all God there are
so many annoying things about Halloween
I would think about Halloween a lot
lately be obviously because it's
Halloween coming up and [ __ ] like that
look Halloween are at let's just say
past ten stop but also I get it if you
want to dress up fine especially if
you're a chick and you want to show your
titties and you're like today's the day
I get to be a [ __ ] without people who's
shaming me and being a [ __ ] I am a sexy
doctor imagine if a doctor came in and
[ __ ] worked on you by the way and had
their tits all fallen out you know you'd
be like I'm gonna die and I'm only in
here for a sprained ankle yeah take two
of these and call me in the morning Oh
honking the titties Scimitar so anyway
but Halloween is like it's like for
chicks and kids you know if you're a
dude dude if you're a dude and you're
like you know what the man there's so
much stuff about it that's annoying that
it's just like first of all here's
what's got to go whenever I step out of
my house in the faint distance I can
hear this [ __ ] thing and I don't know
why you but I don't know where you get
it CBS save on shop right wherever the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] thing is always way in
the background but who thought this was
Pookie [ __ ] that this [ __ ] is always
somewhere on Halloween
and it just goes all night dude what is
it how are the people that bought that
for however much what is the Braley 995
how are the people that bought that not
losing their [ __ ] minds just sitting
watching The Bachelor or whatever in
their living room waiting for [ __ ]
five-year-olds to be trick-or-treating
with their with their single parents
just oh oh oh here's your mounds bar by
the way what are we doing
who wants that if you want to get a
[ __ ] fake paper mache graveyard and
and and and and hang it all up cool man
but but like you know those the noises
are the you know I just don't understand
owing thing and it's not even scary or
spooky it's literally just and you could
hear them no matter where you where you
are you you walk out your way in the
distance even if you live in the field
with nothing around you like what the
[ __ ] is that imagine being that person's
neighbor dude I'd get a louder one I did
a louder one and just turn I get so many
and I put the [ __ ] airhorn next to it
and it would just be like
in there in their bedroom I'd point it
in their bedroom scary huh and then the
way they open up the window would be
like what the [ __ ] I'd be like spooky
huh by the way there's a five-year-old
that needs a mounds bar downstairs
dude that that that above all else this
is God go on Halloween all right that's
got to go okay
here's the other thing dude as funny as
your Halloween costume can be no don't
do it dress it do a vampire this is my
whole thing be a vampire be a cowboy be
a [ __ ] spooky ghost be a mailman do
you know what I mean
don't be I saw the like the guy had to
put his head cut out on a [ __ ] table
and a lamp next to it and he was a
one-night stand like a one-night stand
like that just is just like this is how
hard I grown at that if I was after the
party in that guy's face that's what I
would do then I saw and they always
think that like then someone will take a
picture then post it and be like
Halloween's over
Halloween's canceled this guy best
costume ever
one girl one guy was dressed up as like
a chick and he had a name tag by the way
anytime you need to have a name tag for
a costume go home we think of a new
costume be a [ __ ] UPS guy instead all
right but they they go so we had a name
tag that says Aileen and he had [ __ ]
a bunch of white stuff all over his face
and it was any was it was come on Eileen
like so bad and not funny and not
creative and also a gross guy look like
a [ __ ] glazed donut so bad so that
shit's got to go the cute funny outfits
not not funny you know guys dressing up
as girls thinking it's funny not funny
you're not create you're not just get
get out there do I don't know I never
but if you got a kid and [ __ ]
you know good that's awesome that's
awesome that's when Halloween is fun for
you go you take your kid out your
trick-or-treat
you know and even the [ __ ] kids that
you're like whew that's spooky huh yeah
what does that noise that
oh well it's spooky you know what it
either is it's either a spooky haunted
house or it's a guy of some [ __ ]
[ __ ] who went to CVS and bought this
goddamn thing for 995 and is annoying
the [ __ ] out of the neighbors including
us so either way go get your [ __ ]
mounds bar Peter either way go get your
mother-fucking won 100 grand bar oh is
that what it was
go get your goddamn KitKat you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and let's go hurry up and
hopefully we get over to October 31st
soon come on oh by the way it's 6 a.m. I
mean 6 p.m. I love it how when you're a
real young kid you got to start
trick-or-treating when it's like 4:30
p.m. because you gotta go to bed at 7 um
but anyway how about the kids that are
like too old you know but I can't wait
by the way I've never lived in a
neighborhood where people wouldn't would
knock on my door or ring my door for
[ __ ] treats and [ __ ] but I can't wait
to till that happens and I get me I want
to get the kids that are too old and
just be like hey bro what are you doing
you're too old for this
go [ __ ] change and let's just hang
out you know what you you got candy you
bro you're [ __ ] 15 hey instead of
that go home let's go cruise for chicks
hey dude instead of that let's just hang
out and watch the UFC fight have a my
wife and [ __ ] giving him candy none of
that no no no no no no that shit's for
younger kids this [ __ ] guy right here
we're gonna chill this guy thinks that
he's [ __ ] cool with Halloween nah imma
show em how we do Halloween you get in
here we're giving [ __ ] mounds bars out
to other younger kids because you're
[ __ ] - all dude you shaved once
already I can't wait to do that and then
and I can't wait to [ __ ] be like when
a kid when a guy thinks his costumes
good to be like not good costume did you
get half this candy bar here here's half
the candy bar you ain't [ __ ] go go
your parents should have raised you
better you get your [ __ ] come on
Eileen get out of here dude
yeah but Halloween is cool in like the
warmer states so you don't have to wear
that [ __ ] jacket over your Superman
outfit you know I mean that's such a
hacky comedian joke but it's true you
had to wear your [ __ ] I always had to
wear a coat I remember was the Punisher
one year and my mom was like but you
gotta wear a jack I'm like mom the
punisher doesn't wear I was like ok mom
do you have a long brown trench coat
with a [ __ ] dope collar on it with
bullet holes in it she was like no and I
was like well then I'm not wearing my
[ __ ] New York Jets starter jacket
over my over my hey you know what the
punisher never wore a [ __ ] New York
Mets starter jacket with a hood
arrangers of [ __ ] Rangers at a New
York Rangers shiny starter jacket I had
all those I had the New York Jets
I had the New York Mets and then I had
the shiny Rangers these were all
different times in my idea wasn't like
but like you know oh ma you want me to
wear a [ __ ] poncho nah I should have
dressed up as the [ __ ] guy from that
Arnold Schwarzenegger movie then in the
beginning where he [ __ ] throws the
axe at him
what's that [ __ ] the one reason the
movie Last Action Hero yeah I haven't
get rid of coming in for the save yeah
dude I by the way love Last Action Hero
that movie was this [ __ ] the kid in it
was a bad actor what ever happened to
that kid
what is he all dude what's he was he got
like a print shop somewhere what's his
name Austin of course his name is Austin
Austin O'Brien see that kid Wow hey dude
that he couldn't look good more he's
like in a boy band how old is he now
so he's 37 dude he's my age other kids
naked neither that kid that you know
what he was [ __ ] that home he was
silly and goofy but that kid everybody
was kind of bad in the movie but look
Arnold Schwarzenegger was the [ __ ] but
he stopped acting oh no is he still
acting oh he's still doing it always him
bones go down more
2015 was a slash it all our yesterday's
unnamed nowhere road I mean these are
all [ __ ] the wood is the worst titles
of every anything I've ever heard in my
life
this guy was in all our yesterday's this
by the way all of these all I swear to
God all of these titles that he's in
since 2009 all of these movies I have no
idea what these movies about but I am
guaranteeing you all of these movies
somebody dies a cancer on him guarantee
with all these titles I've never seen
more die in a cancer ass movies than
these [ __ ] titles right here all our
yesterday's of course some guy dies of
leukemia nowhere road of course there
they've got a home with a bunch of acres
and he [ __ ] dies of definitely dies
of cancer defining moments absolutely an
old guy dies of cancer in that right
there and he's like learning [ __ ] the
kids learning [ __ ] through that rain
from stars by the way anytime you've got
the word stars in your title at least
one probably multiple people dying of
cancer in that movie and then in 2009
this word started this is the place and
the place is a place where people die
from cancer and I'll tell you what that
was when he stays like well I really
like doing that movie about cancer he
told his agents like yeah in cancer
movies it was like well isn't my fact we
have rain from stars we've got defining
moments and we've got nowhere road and
you've got all our yesterday's needs
lined me up for the next six years
I guess I'm losing weight for my next
role but it also wasn't him always dying
of cancer was like his mom's or no dude
that's crazy they always come out with a
movie by the way I did one but they
always come out with that movie where
the guys dying of cancer are the girls
dying of cancer and [ __ ] every eight
months there's a movie and it's like
live your life like you've never lived
it before
life is just a bunch of moments all
strung together making this summer
no no it's never in the summer this
November because you're depressed life
as we know it I mean that's gotta be a
movie where a guy's dying of cancer life
as we know it and Michael Caine's in an
oath though it by the way do you guys
never [ __ ] responded to this I sent it
to the group chat remember when I talked
about in episode 32 I think it was
Maurice Nicoll white about how he's like
always like it doesn't matter Aldo ain't
how about this soundbite from Michael
Caine that somebody sent to me recently
but I did a whole episode about how
Michael Caine was just like although it
it doesn't matter huh
I'll do it and they're like hey we've
got a movie about he's like I'll tow it
I'll tow it and then somebody said this
[ __ ] your boys a clairvoyant your boys a
[ __ ] clairvoyant and I said me
descriptor I didn't I don't even need to
read it it's like yeah although it
literally said Oh throw it your boys a
[ __ ] clairvoyant dude
Oh Mike Raskin Who am I that [ __ ]
lady with with the with the what was
that what is named Cleo with the too
many earrings how am i the lady with the
too many earrings this is call Cleo ah
dude that's crazy
oh yes yes replying to my travel agent
because I'm disrespectful
look at that you don't believe me no you
don't you don't [ __ ] believe me that
I'm replying on my travel agent do it
okay well check this out
live on beach um anyway what is the
evolution of cool you just showed me
something Oh Michael oh my he's looking
bright one fires going back to him
Michael Caine website dude he's got to
think of what's the evolution of cool
did we talk about that
Oh evolution of cool Scott Oh poet would
you like to write a poet okay would you
like to open up a chair a poet does it
take time I'll do it just loves would
you like to got one question for you
does it take time yes I'll do it okay I
won't do anything that doesn't take time
but everything takes time you got
exactly that's what he says does take
time yes
then I'll bow it you don't have to ask
me if I'll do it if it takes time but
everything takes time exactly don't
throw it I don't never read the script I
said yeah I'll bow it Wow dude that's
amazing that blew my mind when I saw
that a fan tweeted it to me and I went
like that ah by myself anyway dude yes
so those are the things about Halloween
what else man um you know I mean there's
gonna be so many people did the things
that happen at Halloween it was like you
know everyone's gonna go as the [ __ ]
things were I was like you're such a
[ __ ] ho I love it
everyone's gonna go as those guys little
pomp and Kanye West everyone's gonna go
as Takashi 6 9 you know it's just like
well you know you're gonna get dressed
up as Takashi 6 9 and then go out and
see everybody [ __ ] dress like Takashi
6 9 you gonna look like a bunch of
[ __ ] gonna be like the scene in the
matrix with all the bad guys except
everyone's Takashi 6 9 I'm gonna go as
Neil that you know
dude that's what I'm going if I ever get
dressed up from now on
everyone's going as post Malone by the
way that's the thing I'm gonna do when I
go what next Halloween cuz it's too late
now I'm not into it it's Wednesday but
I'm gonna dress up as Neill
that's what I'm gonna do and then I'm
gonna go in and whoever dressed up as
the most people I'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out all them and I'm gonna be pretend
like it's the matrix everybody's just
like post Malone everyone's getting
fought everyone's dressed as Takashi
six-nine everyone's getting fought and
then I want somebody to film it and then
I want to cut it together and make it
look like that [ __ ] partying matrix -
when neo is beating the [ __ ] out of all
those guys who talk like this mr.
Anderson what was the movie where the
guy's name was Anderton was that [ __ ]
that was a Tom Cruise movie with the
cogs right where he predicts the crimes
in the future Minority Report
dude when they it that's the kind of
[ __ ] that drives me dude this so funny
like minority I think it's Minority
Report right is that the character's
name Anderton he plays the guy whose
last name and Orton right dude just call
him Anderson okay don't make it
different that's not a less name dude
it's Anderson and somebody's like you
know what I'm gonna change it to
Anderton give a little spice oh it's not
spice first of all you got Tom Cruise's
of the lead we love them but spice ain't
what you going for just call them
[ __ ] you know Jim Jones every that's
what the thing about [ __ ]
what's-his-name that used to be good
John Wayne every [ __ ] character he
played wasn't it named John Breaux
that's the [ __ ] man we gotta get back to
that the rock every character he plays
should be the something
hey the hey this summer the rock is the
train in coming soon Chickasha
ooh this summer the rock is the tornado
this summer the rock is the bulldozer
and then he just does too many things
just like this summer the rock is the
lamp and we're like what what's this
these are the characters that John Wayne
played look at this [ __ ] this is the
best okay stay right there
John Blair John Ashley John Claybourne
John tipped and John Delmont John
Middleton like why even change last name
John Dawson John Wyatt John Wyatt posing
as John Rogers John Mason John Scott
posing as Jon Jones you know John Martin
John Higgins and then Chris Morel
they're like you know let's try
something different
then they were then they then they
realize you know what too much went back
to John Tobin then they're like well but
that didn't do well either because his
career was probably dying and they're
like how about rod rod drew and then
that didn't work again John Travers and
then Randy Bowers John West and John
Carruthers Tom Hayden posing as gat
ganda what the [ __ ] is his [ __ ] what is
this like when someone writes a book and
they don't go under the regular pen name
is that what it is
that's what that's actually this [ __ ] I
want to get so famous that I'm like hey
oh that's actually you know what that's
a new goal of mine I want to get so
famous that's what why aren't the
[ __ ] stars doing some cool [ __ ] like
that Tom Cruise bro you got so famous
Brad Pitt that's what I would do
Mark Wahlberg bro change it up okay
listen yeah I want to do the movie but I
want you to bill me as [ __ ] John
Travers that's one that's who I am
playing whoever I'm playing it be like
John Travers in fast and the most
furious and they're like what the [ __ ]
that's Mark Wahlberg and he's like no
it's not oh that would be this [ __ ] Jim
bugger you know that
that's what I want to be I want to be
Jim bugger as Chris nah nah feel like
new crystally a movie I'm like way
talkin about
they're like well yeah you got the new
movie I was acknowledging buggers
I'm Jim buggers in that movie I'm Jim
buggers playing Tim [ __ ]
I'm Jim buggers playing Tim [ __ ] in
that movie
it's crystal No do not say that dude and
if I do interviews I'm either doing a
mass crystal er talking about Jim
buggers or I'm Jim buggers and you would
you talk to me you say Jim but we talk
about and we set it up beforehand that's
how we do it that why don't why don't
these [ __ ] have fun dude
I don't get it we got to have more fun
these stars got to have more fun did you
have everything going or write it and
take a [ __ ] what's going on you have
everything going to write it and take a
[ __ ] alright honey nobody wants to feel
like they're overpaying while shopping
online of course you don't because
you're a person you got a brain but did
you know that there's an easy way to
always get the lowest price it's true
it's called honey and everyone deserves
to know about it honey is a free
shipping tool that automatically saves
you money by searching the internet for
the best promo codes whenever you shop
online that means you get the best deals
without even trying on sites like Amazon
eBay Walmart Macy's Domino's and more
honey does it offer you it always
applies the biggest discount right at
checkout
it has over 10 million members and over
100,000 five-star reviews honey members
have already saved more than 800 million
dollars to talk about backing it up
that's not bad for something that's
completely free and takes just two
clicks to install did I buy a knife on
Amazon for $29 instead of $43 yeah I did
and thank you honey
okay there's no reason not to add a
honey to your browser today it's free to
use and installs in just two clicks get
honey for free I join honeycomb slash
Congrats that's two words join honeycomb
slash Congrats honey the easiest way to
save money while shopping online
stitch fix I just signed up on stitch
fix and I'm excited to receive my new my
my first box signing up was so easy and
you know I look forward to seeing what
they send me
stitch fix is an online personal styling
service that finds and delivers clothes
shoes and accessories to fit your body
budget and lifestyle just go to stitch
fix comm / Congrats and tell them your
sizes what styles you like and how much
you want to spend on each item it's easy
I did it you'll be paired with your very
own personal stylist who will hand pick
five items to send right to your door
then you try them on pay only for what
you love and return the rest shipping
exchanges and returns are always free
there's no subscription required because
I'm ain't about that life you can sign
up to receive scheduled shipments or get
your fix whenever you want stitch fixes
styling fee is only $20 which is applied
toward everything you keep from your
shipment you get it get started now at
Stitch fixed calm / Congrats and you'll
get an extra 25% off when you keep all
24 when you keep all five items in your
box that's an extra 25% off when you
keep all five items in your box that
stitch fixed comm / congrats to get
started today stitch fix calm / Congrats
me undies you know you love them I wore
my spooky pair the other day they've got
pumpkins and jack-o'-lanterns on them
you've heard me obsess over my me undies
and all that I'm amazing colors and
prints they offer but guys did you know
that my undies also makes the world's
most comfortable lounge pants and tees
with fall finally here now is the
perfect time to put these cozy
essentials to the test I got the lounge
pants and I love them and I wear them
you know what when I come home from a
set which is my work day I take off my
jeans because those are the things I
wear out in public and they take on
these lounge pants and I put them on and
guess what I do I feel so comfy and I
watch TV and I'm an adult and it feels
good the lounge pants are made from the
same micromotor fabric as their undies
let me tell you you'll be in fall heaven
when you cover your entire bottom half
with fabric that is three times softer
than cotton my undies also love
celebrating this is why I got the
Halloween prints check out their latest
jack-o'-lanterns print in undies socks
and bra let's best part when you join
the membership you get all this stuff
lounge pants T's and undies everything
me undies makes for less than anyone
else special member pricing that's one
of the perks of the memberships babies
so no-brainer do it 50% off a pair the
most comfortable undies you ever put on
for my listeners to get your 5 15% off
your first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
dot-com / Congrats as my undies comm /
Congrats that's what I got here I got my
me undies on right now I got my beige
kind because I didn't want to clash with
my cool G star raw shirt going on
made by Jaden Smith by the way Jane
Smith hooked up with G star raw this is
not this is just not a commercial but I
got the raw shirts like that texted
Jayden hey buddy your new shirts rock
and he said thanks my man I already
bought one and I wrote that and he said
thanks my man then about two more then I
realized afterwards after I bought them
wonder why he didn't [ __ ] send them to
me after I text him that I liked them
but it's all good I'm not that famous
maybe that's what it is and he's Jaden
[ __ ] Smith that's why - how about
that family huh that family's amazing
dude that feeling really is amazing it's
[ __ ] crazy when you see like how well
adjusted those people are and how famous
they are Will Smith and Jada and willow
and Jaden it's just crazy
and the mom Jada Pinkett smama well I
mean how old must she be and she's
slamming I mean she's gotta be what I
mean just Jada is what 48 how old is to
her mom how old's Jada I mean how old is
Jada they're all slamming the whole
family slamming Will Smith is slamming
Jada is 47 good guess Chris thank you
you're welcome
and her mom is gotta be 20 years older
that 57 67
mean how are you 67 and slammin Jordan
what the slam did ever tell you about
that
no dude when I was a kid I did when I
was a kid I did I went to I could never
spend the night at my friend's house did
I ever talk about this I was so scared
yeah I would talk about how I was scared
and I would never just sleepovers and
one time there's two stories here
actually I can tell one time did I think
about the Freddy Krueger story when I
went over to Chris Siegel's house okay
look I'm gonna tell two stories I think
already told one on the podcast but I
don't know one time well this story the
more the first one isn't really a story
but I was too scared to there was I grew
up in Montclair New Jersey and there was
there was like the bad part in the good
part I live in the good part but there
was like my had friends in the bad part
and I wouldn't sleep over at my friend's
house even in the good part I wouldn't
even sleep over to my friend Matt
Ravenna in next door and he was next
door he lived next door to me and I
would get scared and I would [ __ ] run
home at night from yard to yard and I'd
be like dingdong my mom would open the
door be like mom I couldn't do it what
are you scared of everything birds and
and so so Georgiou Justin McKinnon had a
sleepover party and I was like I'll go
for the party part but I'm not going for
the sleepover because I can't do it cuz
he lived in a bad part of town I guess I
which probably wasn't even the bad part
of town but in my head it was a [ __ ]
lunatic kid and we watched psycho is
what it was that's the the movie with
the the movie by um yeah Norman Bates
and [ __ ] the director Hitchcock Jesus
Alfred chef Cardoz
mister gave me my dad would [ __ ] be
mad at me for not knowing that but
anyway uh not not remembering that I do
I just didn't recall it okay so anyway
yeah we go over and we watch psycho my
dad's like well I don't want you to
watch cycle I was young he was like
that's a [ __ ] crazy scary movie so I
didn't watch it mm-hmm but oh no wait
I'm mixing up two stories Justin
McKinnon would come over and play video
games and every time we play [ __ ]
video games every time Michael Jordan
would make a slam dunk he'd be like
Jordan with the slam he would do that
and he would just keep going Jordan with
the slam like high-pitched dude video
games I wish I liked video games that
Red Dead Redemption [ __ ] came out and at
my friends saying how [ __ ] amazing it
is and I just don't give a [ __ ]
by the way everybody's tweeting me
pictures hey man you're in Red Dead
Redemption
everybody in Red Dead Redemption looks
like me every time someone tweets me a
different screenshot
it's a [ __ ] another guy I guess I
look like a [ __ ] wild wild west
degenerate it's always a guy - that's
cowering hey thanks for that it's always
a guy that's caring to the [ __ ]
they're like sorry I don't know and he's
got like a gun to his [ __ ] six-shooter
ooh his head anyway so I want to play
video games but one time I was with my
buddy this is how [ __ ] this is at the
beginning of the devolvement of me by
the way my buddy was and I genuinely
remembered I was must have been 15 16 my
friend Brandon was playing video games
playing a basketball game and I was like
hey man pay attention to me I need to
tell you something and he wasn't really
paying attention to me and I was trying
to tell him something and he wouldn't
tell me some and he wouldn't listen
and I was like pause the game and he was
like hold on man I'm playing back I'm
playing a basketball game I was like
pause the game and I was like you better
do it and I remember I took my dick out
and I was and I was like I'm gonna pee
on you if you don't pause the game so I
can tell you what I gonna tell you cuz I
need you to pay attention to me and he
says nah man come on and I said listen
to me
I'm gonna pee on you so now you know if
you don't pause the game you're gonna
get peed on therefore if you get peed on
it's your fault and he was like come on
man and he didn't pause it and I peed on
his pants yep
have you peed someone else's pants bro I
peed on his pants I peed on his pants
and he goes what the [ __ ] and he paused
it and I said well there you go now you
pause he you should have paused it
[ __ ] four seconds earlier whenever
piss pants
and I'm remember thinking it's his fault
because I told him what was gonna happen
ha ha ha what a piece of [ __ ] I was you
know what a piece of [ __ ] convinced
myself it was his fault that he got
pissed on from my deck yeah but he
paused it
let's head get [ __ ] done that's some
trump [ __ ] I've guarantee that some
Trump [ __ ] just what Trump does well
it's your fault I told you it's gonna
happen
therefore pissed on you so then yeah so
video games I just don't I don't care
dude I even want to play donkey I III
don't even like with the old ones like
the Mario brother games [ __ ] like that
um I like kind of watching people play
video games kinda I don't want to play
but like the second you got to talk to
another character in a video game it's
like I don't give a [ __ ] there's a guy
we gotta go talk to him see what he has
to say no I want to shoot him in the
head I wanna you know the second game's
got to like when there was the games
that started to be like a but don't make
a noise or you'll alert the guy like get
the [ __ ] out of here I want to jump on
someone's head and then [ __ ]
transport to another world hey don't
make a noise you might not want to use
your gun for this one cuz then you'll
alert all the other guards slide down
the pole and tiptoe over and then choke
them out
hey dude this is a video game I don't
want it to be like how it would actually
have to be for me if someone kidnapped
my daughter and girl you know now but
this is really what it's like for the
[ __ ] ball players you got to [ __ ]
take a few cuts on the on-deck circle to
warm up it helps no no trade your
players no no no no no no no no no no no
no that's basically going to that
[ __ ] restaurant where they they they
have you cook it on the skillet no no no
no you made the [ __ ] restaurant I go
you cook that's it
don't even cook in front of me don't do
the [ __ ]
hey-oh flipping the [ __ ] whoa hey
flipping it on my plate what's that
[ __ ] place Benihana [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
Benny [ __ ] you Hana
cook behind a wall I don't want to see
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you Benny [ __ ] you Hana
and also I don't need to trade players
in my video games do it the team sucks
the team sucks actually no every team is
the goddamn same they're just a
different color how about that
you're the Jets green you're the Broncos
orange no you're gonna trade John Elway
go [ __ ] yourself
no you're not trading [ __ ] that's when I
stop listening about football by the way
I've no idea who's on the Broncos that's
it you're not trading [ __ ] well the
stats aren't [ __ ] stats dude I want a
game pick pick pick Brooklyn or or or or
even if you try to have the crowd you
know like I want it to sound like rap
like bad and I want I don't want the guy
to say first down I want the guy to say
barone that's what I want
look strong box groan being the only
sports grown mean poor thrown that's
what I want dude Oh wrong and when they
run it's like book tick tock tick tock
tick tock tick why did they even add
those sounds in the 80s
why the [ __ ] would they even had the
step sounds if they weren't real step
tick tock tick a lot of you guys don't
know she didn't play video games some of
you guys are my age seven guys are older
you listen to my [ __ ] Park guys we
got older babies and we got younger
babies but some of younger babies don't
even know that they would [ __ ] add
steps and it'll be like [ __ ] dick dick
dick dick hey programmers it doesn't
sound like steps at all just put nothing
I understand if you want to put all
wrong because you know it kind of sounds
like homerun
what and then the paint they don't name
thing that was anytime you want anything
some Japanese guy would just like put
the chords in dude the [ __ ] games
were so funny dude that streets are rate
nothing
did I ever talk about this Streets of
Rage there was a no dude it was I tell
you what dude I put on the streets of
rage [ __ ] theme song for the Sega
Genesis [ __ ] I put on that [ __ ] song
the other day and drove around with it
that [ __ ] is gangster dude that [ __ ] is
gangster
got my girl in the car playing the
[ __ ] Streets of Rage theme song
making her listening to it just [ __ ]
roll a rent rolling around like we're
about to find a [ __ ] chain and a
[ __ ] pipe to beat the [ __ ] out of a
guy with a mohawk and a raincoat on dude
because that's what the thugs look like
in video game land and these streets are
purple brick bro and why are we on a
bridge now for level 6 you know why are
we on a [ __ ] bridge there was always
that video game where it was a Brit
where there was of the bridge level and
you had to hop over the broken bridge
like there were [ __ ] cities that
dilapidated that fixing a bridge
wouldn't happen immediately touchdown at
the end this [ __ ] sound block tech
that's when video games let me play you
this [ __ ] Street so let me tell you
something dude let me play you this
Streets of Rage [ __ ] theme song and
you tell me it's not better than
anything ever that [ __ ] any that's
come out in the last [ __ ]
nine years musically in hip-hop or
anything actually you're gonna go to
youtube.com and I got to YouTube red
because I'm a [ __ ] cuz I back up the
Brinks truck and I got YouTube premium
now because that's how we [ __ ] around
here at congratulate since to do and
I'll tell you what it's only took a 92
episodes to get YouTube red now the
internet it's moments longer [ __ ] now
does that make me mad yes that one fires
fault yes because I always tell him to
fix internet it doesn't work it as fine
okay I'm gonna do I gotta do ads again
here but I gotta [ __ ] play this
[ __ ] streaks or eight scenes I'm
gonna play I'm paying my phone also
every time I move my computer because so
that's cool so it's gonna sound pretty
shitty but let me play this [ __ ]
Streets of Rage song song song or song
on my thing streets of course now it
works Streets of Rage let me tell you
play this [ __ ] video game here we go
Streets of Rage here we go let me get
the theme song here
Oh either Streets of Rage I love when a
video games successful they they have so
many sequels you have no idea about
because you're older now theme this song
is so dope
I wouldn't even disrespect his beep I
[ __ ] to it
you know what I would do to this sit
alone in my chair and just chill I just
think about you plot I would plot and
[ __ ] eat a banana when that [ __ ]
kicks in yep oops down Oh wrong and then
this part right the best part was done
yep
some Japanese guy just putting on a
[ __ ] Casio the first one and then
when it goes
but there's another high part I think
here something like that
there it comes this is where you yep
[ __ ] yeah do it on the night on the town
dudes looking over to the stars
[ __ ] yeah do it just jerking off just
looking over at the City Law Center's
just jerking off pants down around the
ankles plottin shirt on shirts too long
you have to lift it up a little bit to
jerk off just [ __ ] and that's where
you blessed not on a plant and you look
at some ants and you're like got to go
home dude that's the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
are you kidding me bro they should rap
to that
so mysterious it was a world where punks
and ne'er-do-wells took over there was a
dilapidated bridge for more than one
night even though that would never
happen in the world because any big city
would take care of gaping holes and
bridges mr. X of course is his dink has
taken over the world and is only up to
you and one other black guy and a girl
that nobody will play with to defeat mix
mr. X and there will be a level where
you have to get into an elevator and you
don't move sides roll anymore guys just
enter the elevator and beat the [ __ ] out
of you and the elevator keeps going up
for way too many floors even though no
building in this city would be 100
floors a Japanese guy made the Sun
obviously there's been nothing more
Japanese then naming a character Alex
and it's racist because we named the
black guy something like wrench they
don't even know the race is in Japan
they're like oh you know people are
racist against us to [ __ ] call a
black guy wrench [ __ ] holy [ __ ] man
[ __ ] Streets of Rage is this [ __ ]
dude
poop [ __ ] man what were the character
names anyway loot crate what is loot
crate well Luke rate is a monthly
subscription box delivered direct to
your door with exclusive pop-culture
collectibles apparel in gear loot crate
curates designs everything themselves
you can't find these items anywhere else
so no matter what you get out about this
is for you
I enjoy loot crate look here's the deal
everyone's a geek in
some way you're a geek about something
and I'm a geek about some things and
lootcrate satisfies my inner geek 30
over 30 million crates sold the original
and most popular loot crate is curated
is a curated collection of items from
the best pop culture franchises the
November theme is lab laboratory
Laboratory of your British with
cutting-edge and sinister experiment
themed loot you have to check this out
our original and most popular loot crate
is a curated collection of items from
only the best pop culture franchises
every month we're talking the real deal
with the likes of DC Marvel Blizzard
Harry Potter Nickelodeon WWE fallout and
many more you also get a t-shirt in
every crate loot crate packs $45 value
in less than $20 a month so you can't
lose there's sixteen other awesome
crates from gaming to anime so that's
you know those are those are huge and
those are big ones and I like you know
I've been trying to get into gaming in
it and I also do love anime I believe it
or not which I've never talked about on
this show but subscribe now and give
yourself a birthday present every month
this crate will sell out you must order
this week to guarantee yours as this
will sell out get the best surprises
each month from the largest geek and
gaming subscription company geek out in
style with loot crate subscribers are
also automatically entered to win each
month's mega crate a special prize that
looters can win just by being a looter
head on over to loot crate calm to see
this month's mega crate prize for
yourself
subscribe now by going to loot crate
calm / congrats and enter my code
congrats to save an exclusive 30% off
your subscription subscribe now by going
to loot crate calm / congrats and enter
my code Congrats to save an exclusive
30% off your subscription a square cash
you already know the cash up to is the
number one finance app in the App Store
what you might not know is that you can
also put cash up in your wallet with
cash card it's the only debit card that
offers instant rewards and comes packed
with premium features not even a credit
card
can offer like boosts save up to 10%
instantly at Whole Foods Wendy's or
Chipotle and more of your favorite spots
or even $1 off coffee every time you
swipe your cash card at coffee shops
across the country the cash card puts
you in control of your money with extra
in-app safety features that lets you
pause your card with a touch unlike a
credit card there are no fees ever and
the credit check isn't required to get
one download cash app now and get your
cash card for free visit the App Store
or Google Play market now and of course
when you download the cash app and enter
the referral code congrats you receive
$5 and the cash app will send $5 - times
up legal defense fund a true win-win I
have it I got the cash app and I use it
all the time and if you don't then what
are you doing do it
get with the program um god that streets
a rage thing man it brings you back
because that's the thing you used to
listen to music a lot but you used to if
you played video games you played why is
this happening one fire it's annoying
you played video games for a long time
and that was a big part of your
childhood and so that's really nostalgic
I'm gonna play more of this Streets of
Rage here or what other video games were
like this [ __ ] the video games what you
guys tell me on Twitter but what other
video games theme songs were like you're
[ __ ] nostalgic like go listen to some
of those after this episode go listen to
some of those that are really nostalgic
and make you feel you know back like you
were in your parents living room or
whatever that made you let me let me try
and play another one here will it
Streets of Rage 2 - Rage 2 - okay
Streets of Rage 2 the exact same song
same Japanese guy did it
I played future h2 also and then there
was three or four oh man when the bad
guys died I mean how many people I don't
know it was a successful game I don't
know a you guys later but when the bag
when the main bag I died it would be the
guy would go oh and when they threw the
guy here we go
i oh wow I remember that now by the way
you know some shits going down right
there this is when you know some shits
going down you think everything you like
okay well what's going on some weird
shits going on but then when this [ __ ]
happens you know some shits going down
Oh bro that's when I'm looking out over
the city and I take my dick out and then
the same song kicks in streets are h2
exact same thought song except they had
the different beginning and there we go
get a [ __ ] boner all over again
looking out over the city start jerking
off song anywhere not just looking over
the city in the car rolling down [ __ ]
Sunset Boulevard just jerking off in a
convertible looking over at other people
dudes and chicks alike they have no idea
jerking off because of the doors in the
way and then [ __ ]
going into pink dot dick all-out hardest
[ __ ] you guys have almonds they're like
yeah we've got a bunch of raw almonds
over there even though they taste
horrible
just who the [ __ ] would ever buy raw
almonds nice and you take your [ __ ]
hard dick over there and you look
through the almonds and you're just kind
of jerking off and you're like I'm gonna
get these [ __ ] Chipotle almonds then
you go when you bite up to pull the
almonds you with your [ __ ] pick out
on the counter and then you go in your
convertible your jerk up you eat and
[ __ ] it you pull down that's just
jerking off yep so disrespectful the
streets orig - their hard work and I'm
talking about jerking off with the
[ __ ] music over it there's that
[ __ ] thing again
oh they add a little funky that little
fight some fat end up on that little
funky [ __ ] thing that was like the
black guy came in and he was like hey
man let me put this [ __ ] on you get up
you got a funk it out a little bit and
the Japanese guys like what's your name
wrench
this was the boss theme music yep I mean
so basic home run ups down every song in
the 90s was this song I mean it's the
same thing as more combat wow this is
awesome dude thanks for listening with
me you guys Mortal Kombat Theme song 76
million views YouTube same song only a
little bit dopest a little bit more
victorious
test your might
Wow
oh dude the [ __ ] so funny dude
just cancel a call on Brian Cowen
yeah dude I love that the guy who
actually said just your might was
probably just like some [ __ ] fat
overweight white guy that's balding just
your might and then the guy who screamed
a Mortal Kombat in the studio which is
hilarious to think about some guy just
like alright you gotta do more crime
he's just like in a studio I mean just
some [ __ ] regular ass pasty white
guys it's like all right here we go I
gotta feel them in the [ __ ] studio
the guys like nads a little [ __ ] you
got to sell more Victoria's like alright
here we go
dude you know there's guy who did that
you don't think about this [ __ ]
I do bro some [ __ ] guy who wasn't
ripped at all not a mortal kombat
fighter at all just some guy who is a
[ __ ] voice actor just comes in and
gets paid $600 an hour for real to just
go in a [ __ ] studio with egg crate
crates in it that's why it's oh that's
why it's [ __ ] cheaper and better to
get the guy to just go mortal upon bird
touchdown boxed on did he say [ __ ]
brush down touchdown that's how it
always goes in your kid sound like he
says [ __ ] brush down three points did
he say pre points did he say brunch down
look down um bro I have so many texts
it's ridiculous right now you guys ain't
[ __ ] look at your phone how many takes
you got twelve I got 12 and [ __ ] one
hour gone by bro that's how [ __ ]
popular I am do you understand I got
[ __ ] 12 texts
I got 12 taxibro text your Mike text
your mate I didn't mean to say that text
your might
that's what else with their Street
Fighter 2 wow I don't even remember the
Street Fighter 2 theme song let's see
that one SF 2 seem I don't remember that
one
here we go are they so many different
ones guiles theme is it good it's funny
very American according to the Japanese
elite see this one doesn't hold the
nostalgia for me dude gals hair you know
[ __ ] I'm going to kick that son of a
[ __ ] m.bison says so ordered the next
bison wannabe is going to fill it
that was [ __ ] why did how did it
[ __ ] junk or Van Damme play guile the
American nothing is more 90s I'm going
to kick that son of a [ __ ] Bisons I
should show Ord that the next bison
wannabe is going to feel it know who's
coming with me and O's going home and
then one time it goes like this
he's talking to and bison and he goes
like this the most child called meant
damn thing of all time he literally goes
like this dude you got to see the video
podcast because this is really what he
does because that sort of I'm going to
get that son of a [ __ ] Bisons as show
or that the next bison is going to feel
it put that back to back on on the
[ __ ] somebody do a video of it I'm
going to kick that son of a [ __ ] bison
says short that the next bison wannabe
is going to feel it not tough to do that
you know to [ __ ] swing your arm
around and stop it with the other one
schizophrenic I I did say on Twitter I I
don't ever have guests but I want it I
want to do a guest for the 100th episode
and I want it to be John Claude Van
Damme and otherwise I'm just gonna
[ __ ] ride this solo on my dull oh
[ __ ] out wow my [ __ ] bed is kind of
tough man my arm is red from stopping it
I'm going to kick that son of a [ __ ]
bison says sure Lord did the next bison
it m bison wanna be asking the villain
good hey so Ord you know so Ord know
lost your balls Colonel guile I play
guile he should have just played [ __ ]
what was the other guy Zhang Zhang Jeff
the Russian and then just made a [ __ ]
movie based on that guy that movie was
[ __ ] ridiculous I remember when I
watched that movie it was the only movie
up until that point in my life that I
saw to ice in one day like an idiot
because I thought was so funny though I
loved John's of and an imagined the line
writing the line I'm gonna kick that son
of a [ __ ] bite and Bisons ass so hard
that the next bison wannabe is going to
feel it yeah anyway if you're gonna
dress up as anybody for Halloween dress
up his [ __ ] guile from Street Fighter
2 well the last time I dressed up for
Halloween I dressed up as
what's-his-name counter Reeves in
Constantine I had like drawn the tattoos
on my arms and or some [ __ ] and then put
the I don't know put the [ __ ] I don't
remember this shirt on it was like a
just a shirt with a tie and then the
time before that I was I was a ethan
hawke from training day which was so
stupid but it was funny because we had
four other guys do the same thing and
everyone was like you didn't dress up oh
wait hold on wait who the [ __ ] are all
you guys and we like we're all ethan
hawke from training day he just one got
to [ __ ] a hoodie in the jacket and I
go to and shave the goatee and some of
us drew the goatee anyway I'm gonna see
on wit casual this Wednesday
alright well I guess we're done right I
mean we don't need to do anything to
drive this [ __ ] home oh but you know
what dude first of all download my apps
you get to see it first
those parkas first and then also
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and two
rewards code Congrats give five dollars
get five dollars and give five dollars -
times up and thank you you guys man I
have blast this time this was
fun one for me nostalgia and all that
[ __ ]
I have I'm announcing I just announced
new dates on my website I just announced
new dates on my website in 2019 there's
a lot of them so go look and see if your
cities there there are still some that
I'm holding like Minneapolis that are
not on there but they will be eventually
there will be eventually but I got like
Salt Lake City Boulder Colorado st.
Louis Kalamazoo Michigan Windsor Seattle
again Albany Albany Valley Center
California and I'm Hanover Maryland
Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati Lexington
Lexington Albuquerque Santa Fe Phoenix
Phoenix is the biggest place I've ever
played solo that's going to be 5,000
seats so that's five dozen seats oh I
think they all go on sale on Friday for
to the general public but there's
presale codes if you go look up the
individual venues Oakland Newport News
Virginia I don't know what the [ __ ] that
is
Durham Charlotte Greensboro Greensboro
and then two in Las Vegas at different
times and Tucson all right guys Tucson
and then Oh Miami and West Palm Beach in
Jacksonville coming up Atlanta coming up
Los Angeles San Francisco Boston Fresno
Bakersfield Austin and San Antonio San
Antonio that's that'll round out this
the end of this year and then the other
ones will in next year you guys are
great thank you very much
rate and review the podcast please I
want to [ __ ] and keep this train move
and do it and you got to keep the
business growing otherwise you know a
you ain't [ __ ] you guys are the best my
babies remember the world